when it comes to Slovak method for one
of the gods that I get requested to
cover quite often and one that piques my
interest after seeing the work of Neil
Gaiman is Chernabog the god of darkness
and evil with Chernabog recently
featured as a playable God in smite and
making an appearance in the American
Gods TV show and novel it's likely that
interesting curiosity surrounding the
Slovak god of evil will be at an
all-time high
like many deities associated with death
and darkness Chernabog has a certain
degree of mystery surrounding him which
only edited the fear people felt towards
him we don't know a great deal about
Chernabog but we know his name roughly
translated means the black God which
only mean in black and bogu meaning God
although the belief of Chernobyl may
have been held in several countries
including Russia Poland and the Czech
Republic the only historical sources we
have access to happened to be Christian
and we know how Christianity would often
demonize the belief of any other God or
Pantheon so it becomes fairly difficult
for us to gauge how Chernabog would have
actually been seen by the ancient Slavic
people there are some sources that claim
the name Chernabog only began to appear
within the 12th century and mostly
amongst the Western Slavic tribes which
has led to some speculation that
Chernobyl may not have been an ancient
deity at all and the role he played in
Slavic mythology was most likely quite
small
many of his mentions in these sources
refer to him merely as the counterpart
to bela bog the white god but how much
of the white and black good and evil
symbolism was used by the slavic people
was uncertain as we know it to be quite
a Christian concept so now that we've
got some of the context and I guess what
you can call facts out of the way we can
discuss the stories and myths that were
told about Chernabog in the years that
followed Chernobyl was seen by many as
the Lord of evil wherever he went
calamity and disaster would follow
famine disease blight and murder
wherever he turned bad luck a misfortune
accompanied him it's very possible that
the worship of trona book was out of
fear family sacrificing cattle and given
everything they possessed to the God in
order to appease him and save them from
his cruelness and wrath chernobyl paints
this image of a God who thrives on pain
and suffering and almost takes pride in
bringing death for anyone who has seen
or read American Gods this is something
that you'll be quite familiar with as
here he describes death as an art form
boasting to have killed over 10,000
people and washing his hammer in the
blood of those he's slain now there are
some variations of Chernobyl
not seen as inherently evil and as we've
noticed of some mythologies and most
religions there is a tendency to fear
and must demonize any deity that has
some kind of association with death or
the underworld there's a scene in
American Gods where owner Bob describes
where he's from he says that everyone
there is the same color so they instead
argue over different shades of color
his brother Bela Bach had blond hair and
blue eyes so he was seen as the good one
whereas Chernabog had dark hair and dark
eyes meaning that he was naturally seen
as evil and so he became what everyone
expected of him some people have
attributed the battle between the two as
an explanation to the seasons when Bela
Bach was victorious he would bring
spring and summer and Chernobyl would
bring autumn and winter with winter does
come hardship illness and famine and
this could have contributed to the idea
that Chernabog was evil we can liken the
brothers to night and day with one
ruling over the dark portion of the year
and the other the brighter now whether
Chernabog was inherently evil or just
simply misunderstood is most likely a
question that we will never have the
answer to now for those of you wondering
about China books physical appearance
there are quite a few we can explore we
can imagine that because of Christian
influences he was most likely painted as
a demonic figure and if we take a look
at Disney's Kingdom Hearts game where he
appears as a boss you can fight he does
possess many attributes and aspects we
would expect from a demonic figure
having horns razor-sharp teeth but like
wings and yellow or orange eyes and of
course with him being the god of
darkness He Who Must resembles a shadow
this is the same depiction we see in a
TV show once upon a time when he
terrorizes the town of Storybrooke if we
take the approach that Shona book was in
fact not evil then there's a good chance
he may have appeared as a regular Slavic
man perhaps with some darker features
than normal but these features would
never really have stood out unless you
compared them to his counterpart I do
find Jonah Bob to be quite an
interesting figure
mostly because everything we know about
him is fairly uncertain so it's open to
your own interpretation some may choose
to see him as his great demonic creature
that plagued the Slavic people and
others may see him as an evil God who
serves as a counterpart to the good God
there are many sources that do point to
the fact that Jonah book may have never
even existed amongst our Slavic people
and if he did he was a very minor deity
my interpretation of Jonah book is that
if he did in fact exist he would not
have been inherently evil throughout
Slavic mythology the notion of good and
bad is not very apparent and it's only
when Slavic myth became influenced by
Christianity that light and dark
symbolism began to appear if you do have
any ideas and thoughts and trying to
book that you'd like to share and let me
know in the comments below
you
you